[Applaudissements]
yann daboul savez vous du cinéma allons
lui s'intéresse qu'à kim basinger la
samba ouais ben c'est déjà bien au début
de sa carrière jean michel mr a tourné
dans un film pour adultes intitulé jean
michel et les gladiateurs vrai ou faux
dans ces fosses ah non c'est faux valéry
giscard d'estaing sera en fait l'arrière
petit fils de gérard louvin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non
je poursuis donc c'est pas vrai
apparemment ce serait vrai si les partis
c'est vrai que la vérité qui blesse
est-ce que c'est toi ici ce matin et ce
qui brille donc ce rapport au village
préféré des français les yeux dans le
fond girard y aller jamais
[Applaudissements]